notre retour dans le temps aujourd'hui
on remonte en 1971 avec un reportage sur
la fermeture des villages dans l'est du
québec un événement bouleversant qui
laisse des cicatrices encore aujourd'hui
plusieurs émissions avaient traité du
sujet dont la semaine verte
voyez d'ailleurs la journaliste fernande
saint martin qui nous présentait lundi
village
[Musique]
ce désert tout blanc derrière moi était
il ya tes jours à peine le lieu des 110
spectaculaire on n'y a brûlé une
centaine de bâtiments
une centaine de bâtiments qui formaient
le village de saint paulet d'allibert
l'un de ces fameux village devenu des
villages fantômes
parce que la population a été
relocalisée dans les plans d'aménagement
de l'est du québec dans les années 30
québec et ottawa encourage la
colonisation de l'arrière-pays du
bas-saint-laurent et de la gaspésie
l'objectif était d'exploiter la forêt de
développer l'agriculture et de fournir
de l'emploi ou chômeurs mais au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
alors que les villes sont en plein essor
mais région peinent à sortir de la
pauvreté
l'est du québec et l'une des plus
défavorisées au canada ont même pas
capable de récolter les patins et
légumes achetés il ya déjà un droit qui
peut me la raconter mes pauvres plus
j'avais chaque jour parce qu'on agresse
la terre l'intérêt de repos chaque fois
qu'un cas rester à la vie qu'on mène 6
pistons à l'arrière que de rester dans
ces villages le bureau de poste le
garage les services disparaissent peu à
peu
saint paulet d'allibert comptait en 49
53 cents familles mais la migration
était déjà commencé bien avant les
premiers plats de relocalisation entre
50 et 60
l'ouverture des chemins l'avènement de
la télévision avait fait durement
ressentir aux villageois leur isolement
un isolement qui commençait fin novembre
et s'achever en mars à quelques
centaines de familles qui continuaient
de vivre à saint paulet d'allibert
voyait d'année en année laurence décimée
par les années 60 une expérience sans
précédent se met en branle
des dizaines de jeunes spécialistes des
sociologues des économistes des
travailleurs sociaux sont embauchés par
le bureau d'aménagement de l'est du
québec
ils vont à la rencontre de la population
et tentent de trouver avec elle des
solutions aux problèmes de la pauvreté
après trois ans de travail un rapport
contenant 230 recommandations et publié
il l'une d'elles ébranlé campagne on y
propose de fermer plus de 80
municipalités et de relocaliser des
milliers de personnes vers des centres
urbains
finalement ce sont onze villages qui
seront rayés de la carte
pour que la fermeture ait lieu il
fallait que 80% de la population vote en
faveur
un choix déchirant on est chez nous on
paye le loyer on se met notre offert une
autre tous réveillés on est chez nous de
lille kachkar violons sur pauline on a
la paix la liberté que non certains
habitants choisiront de déménager leur
maison de nombreux autres seront relogés
dans des habitations à loyer modique
comme ici à matam un contraste
saisissant par rapport à leur mode de
vie rural
dans l'ensemble les gens sont
particulièrement heureux de leur sort
ils sont contents du conte fonctionne à
ces maisons là par contre la plupart des
gens se plaignent que ça coûte beaucoup
plus cher vivre à matane c'est à dire
vivre dans une ville que de vivre dans
leur paroisse où il vivait
même s'ils ont de beaux intérieurs un
confort assez extraordinaire comparer
avec ce qu'ils avaient avant bien
souvent
quand ils vivent à saint paulin s'ils
avaient besoin de bois il ya rennes en
cours en arrière puis bouchard inard
bill haley l'été il y avait un jardin il
tuer des animaux il si un matin ils
peuvent absolument pas faire ça il faut
absolument qu'ils chauffent avec
l'électricité alors ce qui fait en fait
que la vie de la ville est beaucoup plus
dispendieuse pour ces gens là que la vie
de campagne même aussi sur le plan
scolaire par exemple à saint paulin les
gens pouvaient envoyer leurs feux leurs
enfants à l'école convenablement vêtus
mais disons de façon moins élégante
comme attendu jusqu'à matane bien les
enfants veulent pas c'est pareil comme
tout le monde qui pleurent en pensant
qu'ils vont s'en aller même côté mais
pour plusieurs cet exil est un chapitre
pénible dont ils mettront des années à
se remettre
dit comme ça fait quand vous avez vu que
même plage que vous avez vu les payer
shdm et lorrains qui chemin un petit
chat est pourquoi que j'avais vu la
porte s'ouvrir dans par wise et vous la
voyez que la dernière fois se remet à ça
fait mal acquis
dans les autres villages menacés des
gens refusaient de partir cela donnera
naissance au plus important mouvement de
contestation du québec rural les
opérations dignité car si le
gouvernement avait jugé qu'il n'était
pas rentable de maintenir en vie ces
communautés il n'avait pas mesuré
l'impact humain du déracinement
[Musique]